good morning believe nation today's
message is show up over to you Farrah
gray most people say you have to be at
the right place at the right time I
always say no you have to be everywhere
all the time because your visibility is
just as important as your ability so I
think you have to show up and I find a
lot of times even personally people are
just not showing up anymore you can't
win if you don't play so we have to up
for example right now I find that people
aren't showing up for their
opportunities you know people believe
that opportunity knocks you know once or
twice or annually I would say
opportunity never knocks it's something
you have to go after with the vengeance
living in Las Vegas I even give credit
to people who you know hit the jackpot
there because at least they showed up
and put that dollar into the machine for
a chance so I think you have to give
yourself a chance and show up in your
relationship show up in your on your job
show up in life I don't think most
people show up just in general I think
people want something but as soon as you
ask them to do just a little bit a tiny
bit of work they fall apart they
disappear they don't show up for the
simple things forget about the big
things that that they say that they want
to accomplish and that's maybe less so
for entrepreneurs but there's still a
lot of you guys out there who talk a big
game but never follow through and the
things that you say you're gonna do as
an examples recently co-hosting an event
with our mayor here in in Toronto and
City John Tory we were talking about
mentorship and they did it a bunch of
the people in the audience came to me
and said hey can we meet for coffee will
you be my mentor can we have half an
hour and talk about my business and this
is always a scary thing because I love
giving back but the worst thing for any
mentor mentee relationship is when the
person doesn't follow through like the
worst thing for Mentor is having a
mentee who sucks who does not follow
through who you've just wasted your time
on right time is my most valuable asset
and if you are wasting my time I feel
terrible about myself about that
decision right and so I don't want to do
it again and so what I do is make people
jump through a couple hoops and the
first one was
I'd be happy to connect with you send me
an email you can look me up send me an
email and let's set up a time of the
people who came up to me and asked to do
some kind of mentorship coffee or
whatever only half of them then went
home and actually looking me up and sent
an email ha like how long as I take five
minutes to type in my name find my
website find my contact and send me an
email half of the people didn't follow
through so what I'm supposed to follow
up with you when you want something from
me you're not willing to even do one
step that takes five minutes it's crazy
from there the people who didn't mail me
I suggested hey why don't we do it as a
Youtube hanging up because I'd love to
answer your questions live hopefully we
can help some other entrepreneurs who
are going through the same issues as you
and whatever your business is we can
promote it to my audience understand
that a lot of the times you do this on
purpose a lot of the times the
opportunity is different than what you
first think it's gonna be you're trying
to bang on the door but maybe the way
through is the window right if you just
keep trying to bang on the door you're
not gonna get through when you have an
opportunity often it's not the one you
expect so I wanted the purposely ship to
hang out instead of a coffee meeting so
then we lost a whole bunch of people who
just never responded to the email I
write back to you and say hey let's do
something and you don't even respond the
people who did respond then I said okay
great let's set up a time here's the
email from my assistant email her and
let's set up a time to be able to do it
I didn't copy her on that I wanted them
to take the extra step to email her
introduce themselves and NASA set up a
time one person did it out of all the
people came up and said I desperately
want you to mentor me can we do
something one person followed through to
the end I set up the hoops on purpose
because again I don't want to waste my
time and I know this is gonna happen I
know that most people will never show up
I just assumed that it's not gonna
happen so I need to design these hoops
that take what 20 minutes of work
combined to do maybe probably 10 or 15
minutes total that people are unwilling
to do and I'm supposed to spend my time
with you and help you out when you won't
even invest 15 minutes in a relationship
to move it forward right I just expect
people not to show
and that's the problem and so when you
do show up you immediately separate
yourself from most people because 99% of
the world isn't showing up so be that
person when you say you're gonna do
something do it when somebody gives you
an opportunity even though it may not be
the one that you had in your mind but it
moves you forward it moves you closer to
your goal do it and the way to achieve
in advance is to over-deliver right
whatever task you're given whatever
immediate opportunity you're given no
matter how small it is over deliver give
them way more than they thought they
were gonna get show your value show your
worth and that small opportunity become
something bigger become something bigger
become something bigger when I meet with
people who want to be mentored and I
give them feedback say hey here's what I
think you should do go home and do it
like try it the same people come to me a
month later and say hey I'm stuck on the
same problems like okay well I give you
advice what did you do oh I haven't done
that yet go do the work right what do
you expect me to do when you're not
invest in a time in yourself like people
expected somebody to save them to do the
work for them to give them all the
answers in an execute you need to invest
in yourself you need to show up and do
the work and again when you do that
you're separating yourself from most of
the world because nobody else is showing
up and the ones that do just do the bare
minimum where if you go above and beyond
deliver an amazing experience something
awesome something excellent something
different something unique that's how
you become successful so the question
today today is when was the last time
you really showed up tell me the story
leave in the comments below I'm gonna
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event special
an espresso TV go